[Music]
i grew up on a farm in egypt
being the creative genius that i was i
named our cows
chicken and sheep after family and
friends the uglier the animal the more
likely they would be named after one of
my sisters
i remember one particularly adorable cow
that we got when i was six so i named it
after my best friend at the time
ali a couple of months into
his arrival onto our farm i watched
ali get slaughtered a horrible
experience that i wish
upon no one's best friend's namesake
understandably i skipped meat for dinner
that night
and the following and the following and
the following
until one day my mother was fed up
she snapped at me at the dinner table
and said
you ate burger yesterday why are you not
eating the steak that i just cooked for
you
i stared at my steak then back at my mom
i asked her is burger cow too
to her dismay her efforts to get me to
eat meat that night
backfired i never ate a burger again now
that i knew what it was made of
but six-year-old me is not that
different from many of us
hardly any of the adults i know know how
their food makes it to their table
luckily for my parents by the time i was
13 i'd
reconciled myself with the fact that
humans do kill mammals for food
my parents started making me eat more
red meat
but something still didn't feel quite
right
so being the nerd that i was still am
honestly
i started researching human's
relationship
with food once again
my mother's efforts to get me to eat
meat backfired
after learning about the food industry i
decided to go
plant-based plant-based meant that
i was not eating not only red meat but
any animal product
being plant-based in egypt a country
where one of the biggest religious
celebrations
includes the slaughter of a mammal and
distributing its
meat to charity was the equivalent of
being a pagan
in fact my mom's efforts backfired big
time
this time i managed to make my whole
family
go plant-based unfortunately
it was not due to my masterful rhetoric
it was simply my mother's solution to
not cook
two meals one without animal products
for me
and one with for the rest of the family
but over the first year of going
plant-based as a family we started
noticing something
interesting my mother started
losing weight making her way out of
obesity and my father
reversed his hypertension
but my parents were not doing something
new here
they were simply adopting the diet of
our ancestors
when they didn't have access to a
carcass 24 7
in their fridge but simply roamed around
earth eating plants nuts
and a small animal every once in a while
so why do i have beef with the meat
industry
well six-year-old me had an issue with
the beef part of the phrase
but adult me has an issue with the
industry part of the phrase
all parties are losing it's a horrible
system
the workers are losing the animals are
losing our health is losing
and the planet is losing well
all parties accept the corporations four
of which
control eighty percent of the industry
me today is half as cheap as it used to
be a hundred years ago adjusted for
inflation
and for me to be this cheap someone had
to pay the price along the value chain
the workers pay the price nothing slows
down
the production line not animal
excrements not exhausted workers
not injured hands in some
slaughterhouses not even
the workers urged to use the bathroom
they urinate
and defecate on the production line lest
they slow down a system
that expects them to kill 35 to 45
chickens per minute do the math
that's less that's less than two seconds
per bird
they do this all day long for every
working day of their lives only to be
paid
500 a week pre-tax
it's not a surprise that the animals pay
the price
if you're a cow in america this is what
your life looks like you are
raised on a concrete slab in a stall
barely big enough for your own body
you never touch the grass or see the
sunlight until the day you're hurt to
slaughter
you are fed corn because it's cheap and
it makes you fat
fast even though you did not evolve to
eat it your hooves have rotten black
from standing in your own poop all day
your tail has been cut without
anesthesia to stop hitting the workers
and a cocktail of hormones and some
breathing decisions
is making you grow at unprecedented
rates that your own bones cannot carry
you
but hey you need to grow fast to keep up
with the demand
the average american consumes the
equivalent of
1.5 steaks per day in the form of
chicken
fish bacon any form of meat
this might not seem like a lot to you
except that the world health
organization
indicates that the consumption of
anything more than 50 grams
or the equivalent of a quarter of a
steak
1 6 of what we consume triggers the
onset of cancer
and cardiovascular diseases among many
many others
british research on over 11 000 people
shows that vegetarians are 40 percent
less likely to get cancer and that
vegetarian women
live on average six years longer and
vegetarian men
10 years longer than their meat eating
counterparts
we're literally paying the price in days
of our lives
i have so much beef with the meat
industry because
even though i choose not to eat meat i
am still paying the price
our planet is suffering
cow farts are suffocating us and
men do cows fart a lot
15 of the greenhouse gases are
attributed
to the meat industry the industry is
taking a huge toll on our
resources do you know what's you
eating drinking showering cleaning for
six months
have in common with one kilogram of beef
you both consume the same amount of
water
it's an incredibly wasteful system it's
an incredibly expensive
system so as a plant-based eater
here is what i ask you enjoy
your meat make it a delicacy
not a daily thing eat it once or twice a
week
then once or twice a month and if i'm
doing my job here
a few times a year
don't listen to me educate yourself
watch literally any food documentary
watch john oliver's episode
on meat packing and then make the
decision for yourself
see if you still feel good consuming
certain products
finally invite your friends have vegan
dinners
have vegetarian mondays make it a group
activity
so enjoy your meat
don't listen to me educate yourself and
invite
your friends
wow six-year-old me
was such a visionary
you